welcome back to this Hannity special
Trump versus the resistance President
Trump gave a phone interview on Fox &
Friends this morning and he not only
expressed his support for the chance to
defend himself in a Senate impeachment
trial but also named several witnesses
whom he would like to testify let's
watch there's only one person I want
more than where's hunter and that is
Adam Jeff I want to put that guy with
his uh with his way something that might
have been slightly controversial look I
want to see Adam Schiff testify about
the whistleblower who's a fake
whistleblower but I want the
whistleblower who put in a false report
to testify what to testify most is
shifty shift and I want to find out why
did he make up my statement he made up
my statement and I want to find that out
why did shifty shift it was a crooked
politician he's a corrupt politician why
did he make up my statement good
question meanwhile independents are
souring on the impeachment inquiry
according to an NPR Marist Poll 50% of
independents do not support impeaching
and removing Trump from office joining
us now for reaction to house freedom
caucus chair congressman Andy Biggs
House Judiciary Committee member
congressman Tom McClintock and senior
legal adviser to the Trump twenty20
campaign Jenna Ellis I think Andy and
all three of you but Andy and Tom I
served with in Congress previously but I
think all three of you for joining us
here tonight now Tom I want to start
with you congressman McClintock you are
actually on the House Judiciary
Committee and if the Democrats and I
think this isn't questionable as to
whether or not they move forward but if
they were to move forward the rules are
different and you get to call people the
Democrat the Republicans will get to
call people who would you like to hear
come testify before the House Judiciary
Committee well I would be hoping we
could get Victor shokhin he's the
Ukrainian prosecutor general that Biden
had fired just as he was looking into
the corrupt relationship between Biden's
son and barrese ma that would be a very
interesting conversation to have
you know obviously though the so-called
whistleblower who concealed his
relationship with Adam Schiff it would
be very interesting to hear from I think
that he has ties to the whole cabal that
dreamed up this Russian collusion hoax
to begin with that would be a very
interesting conversation the fact is
that so far the Democrats have only been
we've only been able to hear from their
hand-picked pre-vetted witnesses and
even so their audience is leaving them
and the jury the real jury the American
people are turning against them when the
Republicans actually can call defense
witnesses I think that's going to spell
a disaster for the Democrats now Jenna
you're part of the Trump campaign I
understand that but as you look at this
this indications of what's going on here
Jerry Nadler back well before this even
came up he was preaching and saying that
there was going to be impeachment in
judiciary how do you see America looking
at what's had transpired over the last
two weeks under the with this shift show
oh yeah well America is not being
bamboozled here they see this
impeachment circus for what it is and
this is just of the hashtag resistance
that is simply undermining the president
at every turn that they possibly can get
this is just the next line in the hoax
of trying to remove him from office in a
way that is not American it's not legal
it's not constitutional and I think that
the American people see that President
Trump was totally vindicated through the
impeachment hearings this week because
we just saw speculation and opinion from
these witnesses who think that they can
set foreign policy and they have better
opinions than the sitting president of
the United States that shameful and I
think the American people see through
that and we've seen that even a third of
Democrats now are saying that they would
like the Biden's to be investigated for
potential corruption they see that
President Trump is working on behalf of
the American people they see that he
loves this country and I was so proud of
him for what he said on Fox and Friends
this morning where he's saying bring it
on I want to hear from all of these
witnesses that were denied by chairman
chef and I think that if this does cede
to Senate trial which it shouldn't then
there will be even a more full
exoneration so congressman Biggs
you're there day in and day out with
their colleagues on both sides of the
aisle but do you really think that after
what Adam Schiff and the show that he
put on the hours and hours of testimony
from people who have no direct
relationship to what's going on there
did they move any Republicans over into
the Democratic camp to vote for
impeachment absolutely not the in fact
they I think what happened to them the
last two weeks is they've actually moved
some Democrats of over to vote against
impeachment and right now it's going to
be nip and tuck for them whether they if
they put it on the floor whether they
get the necessary 218 votes to impeach
the president they've really they've
really botched this thing up bad Jason
and what's happening is when you see the
the independents cratering on this issue
it means that members of Congress are
going to create on this issue as well
because they they don't want to get
unelected because they take a bad vote
on impeachment yeah I think Nancy Pelosi
has her hands full the banan see Pelosi
I know is gonna pull this and she'll do
focus groups go like this put her finger
to the wind but I tell you the support
is not there and I think they're gonna
have to come up with a new game plan
that's just my prediction but
congressman Jenna thank you so much for
joining us